Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你一直想知道如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. So, I was trying to work out what to talk about today because I've got some guest podcasts lined up, but I haven't recorded them yet but they are coming so you might be like oh there's been a lot of Marianne lately but yes there's going to be another one of me today and if you're listening but would rather watch you can come along to Dr Marianne Trent on YouTube and see what I'm wearing today. So I was trying to work out what to do. I was thinking I could do this,
我是Marianne Trent博士，也是一名合格的临床心理学家。我一直在思考今天该聊些什么，因为我安排了一些嘉宾访谈，但还没录制，不过它们很快就会上线。所以你可能会觉得“最近Marianne出现得有点频繁”，但没错，今天还是我一个人。如果你正在收听但更想观看视频，可以去YouTube搜索Dr. Marianne Trent，看看我今天穿了什么。我当时在想该做些什么，
I could do that. And then I thought, no, I know what I'm going to do. I'm going to talk about when you want to quit your job. And we've already done an episode about when you can't be bothered to be a psychologist. And we've already done an episode about when you're hurting and you feel like quitting. But today's going to be slightly different because it's going to be about actually, no, this, yeah, this isn't for me. I'm going to change my job. And it's very strange timing because I was literally just setting everything up to get sorted, looking for the right hole for the mic wire and all of that. And then my computer alerted me to the fact that Liz Truss has literally, as of about a couple of minutes ago, resigned. It's like breaking news as I speak right now.
我能做这个，也能做那个。然后我想，不，我知道该做什么了。我要聊聊当你想要辞职时该怎么办。我们之前做过一期关于“当你不想当心理学家时”的节目，也做过一期关于“当你感到痛苦并想放弃时”的节目。但今天的内容会略有不同，因为它关乎于“不，这真的不适合我，我要换工作”。现在的时机非常微妙，因为我刚才还在设置设备，寻找麦克风线的合适位置，结果电脑提醒我，就在几分钟前，Liz Truss辞职了。这简直是我说话时的突发新闻。
Twitter will be a light and you should definitely if you're not already following me on Twitter come along and follow me Dr Marianne Trent yes it will be an absolute furore but it has been already hasn't it I also would welcome your comments and thoughts about how you navigate being an aspiring psychologist or mental health professional in the world right now on media and social media. So yeah, let me know. Come along to the Aspiring Psychologist Community brackets free group on Facebook and let me know what's going on for you in that realm right now. But that's an aside. So yeah, the social media will be a light. I presume there'll be a general election now. It's been
推特上肯定炸锅了。如果你还没关注我的推特，一定要去关注我（Dr. Marianne Trent）。没错，这绝对会引起轩然大波，其实已经开始了，不是吗？我也欢迎大家评论和分享，谈谈在当今世界、媒体和社交网络环境下，作为一名有抱负的心理学家或心理健康专业人士，你是如何应对的。所以，请告诉我。欢迎加入Facebook上的“Aspiring Psychologist Community”（免费群组），告诉我你目前在这个领域的情况。但这只是题外话。总之，社交媒体肯定会炸锅。我猜现在会有大选了。这真是
a pretty dodgy time, hasn't it? Not an enviable reign, regardless of what your political allegiances are, not an enviable role at all. And sometimes in psychology and in mental health, we also have that too. You know, on paper, the job sounded amazing, you know, on paper, like as you spotted it, perhaps on NHS jobs, or maybe in your local paper or you know on some sort of recruitment consultant website you were like this is it this is this is my job you know this is a bit of me so it might be that it was you know this long-awaited um assistant psychologist position and you were like you know your little ears pricked up, I've been there, I've been there, you know, you suddenly see there's an assistant psychologist
一段相当艰难的时期，不是吗？无论你的政治立场如何，这都不是一个令人羡慕的职位，一点也不。有时在心理学和心理健康领域，我们也会遇到这种情况。你知道，在纸面上，这份工作听起来棒极了。比如你在NHS招聘网站、当地报纸或某种招聘顾问网站上看到它时，你会想：“就是这个，这就是我的工作，这很适合我。”可能这是一个期待已久的助理心理学家职位，你的小耳朵立刻竖了起来。我经历过，我懂那种感觉。你突然发现附近有一个助理心理学家
job actually available near you. You know, it's just about travelling distance or maybe it's even in your home city and you're like, oh, wow, this is it. You get that feeling. You're like, this is my time and I'm ready for the next step. And this is my job. Get out the way, everybody else, you know, do your best, but this job is mine. And you just get that sense and, you know, you apply and you get through to the, you know, maybe you get through the first round of applications. Maybe you even get, you know, the interview and maybe you get told you're like your final two and they want to see you again I don't know like uh but you you know you get some feedback eventually that you you're the chosen one you know you've got this job and
职位空缺。它就在通勤距离内，甚至就在你所在的城市，你会想：“哦，天哪，就是这个。”你会产生那种感觉。你会想：“这是我的时刻，我准备好迈出下一步了。这就是我的工作。其他人靠边站，祝你们好运，但这份工作是我的。”你就是会有那种感觉。你申请了，可能通过了第一轮筛选，甚至可能参加了面试，被告知进入了最后两名，他们想再见你一次……我不知道，但最终你得到了反馈，你是那个天选之子，你得到了这份工作，
you're like hallelujah hallelujah you know it is my time and I'm ready for the night step and the universe told me this was going to be my job and here it is like amazing how am I celebrating you know uh buying some shoes buying a nice candle uh you know coffee with a friend I don't drink coffee don't know why I said coffee you know herbal, herbal tea for me, you know, buying a nice outfit, going out for dinner, how else do you celebrate, please do let me know, how do you celebrate when you do well, I try not to reward myself with food, try not to have, although if I was, I just got a light and intrusive thought then, if there was a Ben's Cookies nearby, which I think might only be in Brighton now but there used to be some across the uh yeah across the country I think there might only be
你会想：“哈利路亚，哈利路亚，这是我的时刻，我准备好迈出下一步了，宇宙告诉我这就是我的工作，它就在这里。”这太棒了，我该怎么庆祝呢？买双鞋？买个漂亮的蜡烛？和朋友喝杯咖啡？我不喝咖啡，不知道为什么我说了咖啡，应该是花草茶。买套漂亮的衣服，出去吃顿晚餐。你还会怎么庆祝？请一定要告诉我。当你表现出色时，你是怎么庆祝的？我尽量不通过食物来奖励自己，虽然刚才脑子里闪过一个念头，如果附近有Ben's Cookies（我觉得现在可能只有布莱顿有，但以前全国各地都有），我可能会买个巧克力橙子味的饼干来庆祝，因为它们太棒了。所以，如果你是Ben's Cookies，想给我寄点饼干，谢谢。
Brighton now if there's a Ben's Cookie nearby I might well celebrate with a chocolate orange Ben's Cookie because they are amazing so yes if you are Ben's Cookies and you'd like to send me some thanks um so uh right yeah when you get this job and you're like this is gonna be incredible and then you start and it's just not quite you know something doesn't quite feel quite right it isn't quite what you imagined but your name badge says you know assistant psychologist or whatever it is that you wanted to be and you're like so it name badge says you know assistant psychologist or whatever it is that you wanted to be and you're like so it's worth it you know I knew this wouldn't be easy but life isn't easy so I'm gonna just push it down I'm not gonna pay attention to it because
好了，当你得到这份工作，觉得它会非常不可思议，然后你入职了，却发现有些不对劲。它并不完全是你想象的那样，但你的名牌上写着“助理心理学家”或者其他你想要的头衔，你会想：“这很值得。我知道这不会容易，但生活本就不易，所以我打算压抑这种感觉，不去理会它，因为
it's really cool you know love this job um so for me when I was on a placement once and I turned up and you know without even basically knowing anything about me on day one I was sort of just given 10 files and it was like very much feeling part of the conveyor belt there not feeling at all like an individual clinician and it's like small things like that that you might notice that you're like this kind of doesn't feel that comfortable to me this isn't quite what I imagined and in the brand new book the aspiring psychologist collective as well there's a couple of stories of people who are like yeah like with hindsight that wasn't an assistant psychologist job that was like just shuffling papers you know this isn't what
这真的很酷，我喜欢这份工作。”对我来说，有一次实习时，我第一天去报到，他们甚至根本不了解我，就直接给了我10份档案。感觉就像流水线上的零件，完全不像一个独立的临床医生。就是这种小事，你会注意到，你会想：“这让我感觉不太舒服，这和我预想的不太一样。”在我的新书《The Aspiring Psychologist Collective》中，也有几个人的故事，他们说：“事后看来，那根本不是助理心理学家的工作，只是在整理文件。”这真的不是
I imagined an assistant psychologist role or other relevant experience role please you know fill in your own um dream job there um isn't what i imagined it would be like and of course that's not really okay is it so you know that you want to get enough relevant experience and you want to get um you know the right kind of experience under the right kind of supervisor to be able to hear my husband doing some percussion as he walks around the house thanks noisy husband um he is a drummer and he makes a lot of noise um so and my children are both learning to be drummers as well so they also make lots of noise very noisy house um anyway so yeah like you're just like this isn't what I thought and although this experience is key to me, it's getting to the position now, perhaps not on day one, we might have zoomed past a little bit, where you're like, hmm, I'm not sure this is about me. can be internalizing the experiences we're having we can think well it must be me I must have
我预想中助理心理学家的角色或其他相关经验的角色（请填入你自己的梦想工作）。这真的不是我预想的样子。当然，这不太对劲，对吧？所以你知道，你想要获得足够的临床经验，想要在合适的督导下获得正确的经验……我能听到我丈夫在屋里走动时敲打着节奏，谢谢你，吵闹的丈夫。他是个鼓手，制造了很多噪音。我的孩子们也在学打鼓，所以他们也制造了很多噪音，家里非常吵。总之，你就是会觉得：“这不是我想要的。”虽然这段经验对我来说很关键，但现在到了这个阶段——也许不是第一天，我们可能跳过了一点——你会想：“嗯，我不确定这是否适合我。”我们可能会内化这些经历，认为：“一定是我的问题，我肯定
misunderstood or maybe it was the way I handled x or y and you know I remember that one time when I did struggle to get on with someone so maybe it's you know it's just something I've done but as time goes on and you're still asked to do things that don't feel like they're utilizing your skills to the best potential or they're asking you to do things that don't feel that comfortable or maybe even that robust you know maybe you're thinking this is not a safe service for me to be in. You know, it gets to the point where you're like, I don't know if I want my name associated with this service sometimes, you know, and you're thinking about, is whistleblowing?
误解了什么，或者也许是我处理某事的方式不对。”我记得有一次我确实很难与某人相处，所以也许是我做错了什么。但随着时间的推移，如果你仍然被要求做一些无法发挥你最大潜能的事情，或者他们要求你做一些让你感到不舒服，甚至是不稳妥的事情——也许你会想：“这对我来说不是一个安全的执业环境。”你知道，这到了一个地步，你会想：“我甚至不知道我是否想让我的名字与这个服务挂钩。”你开始考虑，这是吹哨吗？
You know, I've definitely been to the training on whistleblowing. Is this safe? And some aspiring psychologists have gone ahead and whistleblown um and then of course there shouldn't be any reason why you shouldn't continue in that job because of course you know we've got protection for whistleblowing and in case you're listening to this was like i don't know what whistleblowing is it's when you see something unsafe or um not okay and you alert um probably the whistleblowing department um in in your trust or in your in your overarching service um to say i'm i've got clinical concerns about this service or this person this is not robust this is not safe um
我肯定参加过关于吹哨的培训。这安全吗？一些有抱负的心理学家已经选择了吹哨。当然，没有任何理由让你因为吹哨而不能继续那份工作，因为我们有针对吹哨人的保护机制。如果你在听这段节目时不知道什么是吹哨，它指的是当你看到某些不安全或不妥当的事情时，向你的信托机构或上级服务部门的吹哨部门发出警报，说：“我对这项服务或这个人有临床方面的担忧，这不稳妥，这不安全。”
so that might be one of the reasons that you're feeling that this is not the job for you. But if you were to whistleblow, it could feel like hot water, but it ought not to, because you're supposed to be protected as a whistleblower. But I know when people have been in that position, that sometimes it's challenging, but we still need to make sure that we're protecting the service users. We're protecting the public. We're protecting, you know, just providing safe, robust, ethical, evidence-based services with appropriately qualified clinicians. So I remember when I was, I know some of you listened to this to get the random insights into my life. But when I was very young, I was, I'm going to say 11 or 12, something like that.
所以这可能是你觉得这份工作不适合你的原因之一。但如果你真的吹哨了，可能会感觉像是在“热水中”，但本不该如此，因为你应该受到保护。但我知道，当人们处于那种境地时，有时会很艰难，但我们仍然需要确保保护服务对象，保护公众。我们必须提供安全、稳妥、合乎道德、基于证据的服务，并由具备适当资格的临床医生来执行。我记得当我……我知道你们有些人听这个节目是为了了解我生活中的随机见解。但我很小的时候，大概11或12岁左右，
And I was at secondary school. I basically looked a bit like this, really. I looked a whole lot different, despite the fact that that is nearly three quarters of my life away ago now um but yes we were being taught German so it can't have been year one because year one we did just French but year two we did German if we'd done okay at French too much information anyway I think it was either year eight or year nine um and then the teacher was dreadful and also couldn't hold the attention of the class and couldn't hold the respect of the class either. People who would ordinarily be very pro-social, very thoughtful members of the class were being awful you know it was this teacher brought out some sort of feralness in people who ordinarily would be really good diligent students like myself included I think like just
我在上中学。我当时看起来基本就是这样。虽然那已经是四分之三个世纪前的事了，但我看起来确实很不一样。当时我们在学德语，所以不可能是第一年，因为第一年我们只学法语，但第二年我们学了德语（如果我们法语学得好的话）。信息量太大了，总之，我觉得那是八年级或九年级。老师很糟糕，无法吸引班级的注意力，也无法赢得班级的尊重。那些平时非常合群、非常有思想的同学表现得非常糟糕。这位老师激发了人们内心某种野性，包括我在内，那些平时非常勤奋的学生也……
just there was lack of respect there and that was very difficult and it got to the stage where I think we'd all complained you know we've sort of tolerated it to begin with and to begin with it's quite fun because you get to kind of mess around and but after a while you're like this is just this is a waste of my time and I am 12 you know uh and that doesn't happen easily no but it got to the stage where we were so concerned about that that we were raising that regularly with other staff. I guess it didn't feel safe at times either, you know, even though we're just in a classroom, it felt like chaos. And there was no discernible talent for teaching German observed. And so in the end, this teacher, I'm trying to stay genderless here,
就是缺乏尊重，这非常困难。到了后来，我想我们都投诉了。起初我们还能忍受，刚开始还挺有趣的，因为可以胡闹，但过了一会儿你会觉得：“这简直是在浪费我的时间，我才12岁。”这不容易发生，但确实到了那个地步，我们非常担心，以至于经常向其他教职员工反映。我想有时甚至感觉不安全，尽管我们只是在教室里，但感觉就像一片混乱。而且完全看不出这位老师有教德语的天赋。所以最后，这位老师（我尽量保持性别中立，
I think I have so far, this teacher was dismissed. And it was later investigated that this teacher had never actually qualified as a teacher, in fact, wasn't German, which shouldn't matter, but was Austrian. And so it just was chaos, you know? So I think they do speak German in Austria, don't they? But for me at the time, it was like a big deal, like teaching us German and not even from Germany. But yeah, sometimes the wrong people are in the right job and so you might find yourself in a service where you've got someone that is a wrong person you know so hopefully not as quite chaotic as in a room full of 11 and 12 year old wildcat kids um but you might you might you know this might resonate with you you might be like yes i can immediately bring someone to mind who um you know this is just not a good fit for the service not a good fit for
我想我目前做到了），这位老师被解雇了。后来调查发现，这位老师从未获得过教师资格，事实上，他不是德国人（这本不重要），而是奥地利人。所以当时简直是一团糟。我想奥地利人确实说德语，对吧？但对我当时来说，这可是件大事，教我们德语的人竟然不是来自德国。但确实，有时错误的人在正确的岗位上。所以你可能会发现自己身处一个服务机构，里面有错误的人。希望不像我那个充满11、12岁野孩子的教室那么混乱，但你可能会产生共鸣，你会想：“是的，我立刻就能想到某个人，他不适合这个服务，也不适合
me personally and I was just reflect I'm a little bit behind with Married at First Sight at the moment if you're watching that um you might well be ahead of me but I was on the final dinner party um last night for Married at First Sight UK and like there's some people as soon as they walk in they just bring the energy of the room down and it's like oh I don't know if you guys have got a whatsapp group for watching reality tv with your other psychology friends but I have and we're all like oh did you see that did you see that yeah there's some people in services that are like that too so basically all of these many factors including you know toxic culture about work finish and start times and not stopping for your lunch always stop for your lunch people I do if you're like oh I'd like to hear more about what Marianne does for lunch then
我个人。”我正在反思……我目前看《Married at First Sight》有点落后了，如果你也在看，可能比我进度快。我昨晚看了英国版《Married at First Sight》的最后一场晚宴，有些人一走进来就会让整个房间的气氛变得压抑。我不知道你们是否有一个和心理学朋友一起看真人秀的WhatsApp群组，但我有。我们都在说：“哦，你看到了吗？你看到了吗？”是的，服务机构里也有这样的人。所以，所有这些因素，包括关于工作结束和开始时间的有毒文化，以及不休息吃午饭（大家一定要记得吃午饭！如果你想听更多关于我午饭吃什么的内容，
please do listen to the previous episode which was episode 45 where I talk in detail about my love of lunch um so yeah like you just very quickly for a variety of reasons coming to the conclusion that this job is not a bit of you this is not for you and the best conclusion you can think of is to leave um to pack up your troubles and your old kit bag and you know see if you want to take that that um trust pen with you that never works very well because I could say pack up your desk but I never had one never really had one in NHS services I did have a locker in my most recent service but even being able to find a chair at times was problematic so um yeah you know see see whether you've got a notebook that they're going to let you take with you um but you might decide that you need to look for a new role um
请听第45期节目，我详细谈到了我对午餐的热爱）。所以，因为各种原因，你很快就会得出结论：这份工作不适合你。你能想到的最好结论就是离开，收拾好你的烦恼和旧行囊。看看你是否想带走那支从来不好用的信托机构的笔，因为我不能说“收拾好你的办公桌”，因为我在NHS服务时从来没有过办公桌。我最近的一份工作里有个储物柜，但有时连找把椅子都很难。所以，看看你有没有什么笔记本可以带走。但你可能会决定你需要寻找一份新工作，
that your time in this service is limited and that can lead to a whole host of difficult um emotions um in yourself you know especially if you don't yet have a job to go to. So, you know, you might be in a position where you're having to stay in a job that you don't want to be in because, you know, you've got to finish your qualification or if you don't stay in it, there might be some sort of financial consequence or, you know, because you're worried about, you know, having at least six months on your CV or you really want that reference on your CV, for example. And to that, and of course, you might just need the money, you know, which is very real and a very pressing concern.
你在该服务机构的时间有限，这可能会在你内心引发一系列困难的情绪，特别是如果你还没有找到下一份工作的话。所以，你可能不得不留在一份你不想做的工作中，因为你必须完成你的资格认证，或者如果你不留下来，可能会有某种经济后果，或者因为你担心简历上至少要有六个月的工作经验，或者你真的很想要那份简历上的推荐信。当然，你可能只是需要钱，这非常现实，也是一个非常紧迫的问题。
But we also need to think about you being important. And, you know, this is likely not a case of you being a bad fit for psychology or for the mental health career that you are pursuing but this is quite possibly localized to this one service and to the people that you have met in it um and i'm very aware also not just that today is the day that liz truss has resigned but we're also um you know in the first stretch of um doctorate training courses and that imminently people will start their first placement or their third placement or their fifth placement depending on how the courses are structured that was the timing autumn for me when I was a trainee clinical psychologist so first would usually run September October usually October until around March. I would always take a week at the end of placement to have a nice break.
但我们也需要考虑到你自己的重要性。这很可能不是因为你不适合心理学或你正在追求的心理健康职业，而是局限于这一个服务机构和你遇到的这些人。我非常清楚，今天不仅是Liz Truss辞职的日子，而且我们正处于博士培训课程的第一阶段。人们很快就会开始他们的第一次、第三次或第五次实习，具体取决于课程的结构。对我来说，当我还是临床心理学实习生时，秋天就是那个时间点。第一次实习通常从9月或10月开始，通常是10月到次年3月左右。我总会在实习结束时休一周假，好好放松一下。
And then the next one, I think I start around April time and run until August, September time. Depends on the dates. And then obviously you'd have the same cycle but for placements three and four and five and six the following year so yeah always trying to illuminate the process in case you don't know about the processes but if you do know that already then sorry but try to make this as accessible as possible and to save you any future Googles. So yeah, at this point, let's just take a quick break to hear from one of you guys about what it's like to be just in my world. Yeah, this is a good one. Hope you enjoy. Dr. Marianne Trent is here to help aspiring psychologists. She can help you become a success.
然后是下一次，我想是从4月左右开始，一直持续到8月或9月。取决于具体日期。然后显然，第二年实习三、四、五、六也会有同样的周期。所以，我总是试图阐明这个过程，以防你不了解。如果你已经知道了，那很抱歉，但我尽量让它变得通俗易懂，省去你以后搜索的麻烦。好了，现在让我们休息一下，听听你们中的一位分享在我的世界里是什么感觉。是的，这是一个很好的分享。希望你喜欢。Marianne Trent博士在这里帮助有抱负的心理学家。她能帮助你走向成功。
She has books, podcasts, and does a Q&A. She's here to help in so many ways. It's Dr. Marianne Trent. Dr. Marianne Trent. Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Lizzie and I work as a Senior Psychological Wellbeing Practitioner. I first became aware of Marianne Trent through her compassionate lives on Facebook throughout application season for the DECLIN. I then got hooked on her Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which really helped me to
她有书、播客，还做问答。她以多种方式提供帮助。她是Marianne Trent博士。Marianne Trent博士。Marianne Trent博士。我叫Lizzie，是一名高级心理健康从业者。我第一次知道Marianne Trent是通过她在Facebook上的“Compassionate Lives”直播，那是在DECLIN申请季期间。后来我迷上了她的《Aspiring Psychologist》播客，这真的帮助我
think about how my experiences have shaped me as a practitioner. The Clinical Psychologist Collective book allowed me to be kind to myself, as I learned that very few people have a straightforward journey to training. I was then lucky enough to be one of the first to join the Aspiring Psychologist membership, and this means I have what's affectionately known in my house as Marianne Mondays. As on top of a new podcast episode, I also have a session on most Monday evenings on topics such as the application, research, and various modalities such as CBT, psychodynamic approaches, or cognitive analytic therapy with a host of experts. The community Marianne has created and the support she offers has been invaluable so far this season.
思考我的经历是如何塑造我成为一名从业者的。《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书让我学会善待自己，因为我了解到很少有人能拥有顺风顺水的培训之旅。后来我很幸运成为第一批加入“Aspiring Psychologist”会员的人，这意味着我拥有了家里亲切地称为“Marianne Mondays”的时光。除了新的播客节目，我大多数周一晚上还有关于申请、研究以及各种模式（如CBT、心理动力学方法或认知分析疗法）的课程，由多位专家主持。Marianne创建的社区和她提供的支持在本季对我来说非常宝贵。
I'm learning so much about myself and the world of clinical psychology. I highly recommend the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, Marianne's books, and the Aspiring Psychologist membership to anyone thinking about clinical training. She can help you become a success. She has books, podcasts, and does a Q&A. She's here to help in so many ways. It's Dr. Marianne Trent. Dr. Marianne me. I didn't know that. Yeah, I would love to know how many of you first learned about me, frankly. When did I first darken your door or brighten your vista, maybe?
我正在学习很多关于自己和临床心理学世界的知识。我强烈向任何考虑临床培训的人推荐《Aspiring Psychologist》播客、Marianne的书籍以及“Aspiring Psychologist”会员。她能帮助你走向成功。她有书、播客，还做问答。她以多种方式提供帮助。她是Marianne Trent博士。Marianne Trent……我不知道。是的，坦白说，我很想知道你们有多少人是第一次认识我。我是什么时候第一次出现在你的生活中，或者照亮了你的视野？
How did it feel for you? When did you first hear about me? And, you know, was that a good thing? Or were you like marry what marry who let me know um but yeah if you'd like to leave me an audio testimonial um please do head along to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast um and if you've read one of the um psychology books and you let me have that testimonial before the 31st of um october which is halloween which is coming up imminently if you do that before halloween uh then you'll be entered into a draw to win a one-to-one psychology coaching session with me on the first second, 2nd or 3rd of November,
你当时感觉如何？你第一次听说我是什么时候？那是一件好事吗？还是你会想：“Marianne是谁？”请告诉我。如果你想给我留下音频感言，请前往我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast。如果你读过其中一本心理学书籍，并在10月31日（万圣节，很快就要到了）之前给我发来感言，你将有机会参加抽奖，赢取与我进行一对一心理学辅导的机会，时间在11月1日、2日或3日。
just in case you wanted to use that session to tweak your form before submissions, to have a look at it together. So I'm going to be closing the draw on the 31st of October, which is the day of the next Compassionate Q&A as well. But I won't do the draw until the 1st of November because I want to make sure that everybody before midnight can get their entries in if they would like to. So yes, there's other information about how you can enter the competition in the show notes, but also on my website. So if you go to www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash my hyphen books you will see all the information you need there so we're thinking about deciding
以防你想利用那次机会在提交申请前微调你的表格，一起看一看。我将在10月31日关闭抽奖，那天也是下一次“Compassionate Q&A”的日子。但我不会在11月1日之前进行抽奖，因为我想确保每个人在午夜前都能提交他们的参赛作品。是的，关于如何参加比赛的其他信息在节目说明中，也在我的网站上。所以如果你访问 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/my-books，你会在那里看到你需要的所有信息。所以我们正在考虑决定，
and indeed finding a new job and knowing that that's okay so of course if it feels safe to do so you should be discussing some or all of this with your supervisor and with your manager as well, who might not be your supervisor, because some services have different managers than supervisors. But it doesn't always feel that safe to do. But you could also consider talking to HR. If you're unionised, you could also consider talking to your union. And again, like I said, it might involve talking through policies and procedures and potentially whistleblowing. But it might just be that you're like, this is not the job for me. This is not what I imagined. This is not what I think an assistant psychologist role is. I feel like a skivvy.
确实，找到一份新工作并知道这没关系。当然，如果感觉安全的话，你应该与你的督导以及经理讨论部分或全部内容（经理可能不是你的督导，因为有些服务的经理和督导是分开的）。但这并不总是感觉那么安全。但你也可以考虑与人力资源部门谈谈。如果你加入了工会，也可以考虑与工会谈谈。再说一次，这可能涉及讨论政策和程序，甚至可能涉及吹哨。但可能只是你觉得：“这不是适合我的工作。这不是我预想的那样。我不认为这是助理心理学家的角色。我觉得自己像个打杂的。”
This is not for me. I just paused for a brief moment there to check I wasn't gonna be offending anybody with an ulterior meaning for the word skivvy I think we're okay with that so apparently it does mean a female servant who's asked to do menial tasks so I'm gonna open that up and suggest that regardless of your gender you can be a skivvy, you know, asking someone's asking you to do stuff that you just think this is not my role. You know, this isn't about being too posh to do some jobs or thinking it's not my role. You know, I have done washing up and all sorts and kind of dived in to help support the team and do different bits and pieces that you wouldn't necessarily think are the roles of an aspiring or qualified psychologist but you know things to support
这不是我的菜。我刚才停顿了一会儿，确认一下我不会因为“skivvy”（打杂的）这个词的潜在含义而冒犯任何人。我想没问题。显然它指的是被要求做琐事的女性仆人。我要把它扩展一下，建议无论你的性别如何，你都可能成为一个“打杂的”。你知道，有人要求你做一些你觉得“这不是我的角色”的事情。这并不是说太高傲而不去做某些工作，或者认为这不是我的职责。我洗过碗，做过各种各样的事情，也曾投入支持团队，做一些你未必认为是心理学家职责的事情，但为了支持
the team and to have a cohesive um a cohesive environment you know like going to tea dances and things um with uh with with clients when I was an inpatient lovely memories but not specifically an assistant psychologist role but um yes we're not talking about that we're talking about stuff that feels like it's not using your skills ever you know and you've worked hard to develop those skills so and of course um sometimes as I was saying you, at this sort of time, people are doing trainee clinical psychology roles, perhaps for the first time. And that balance of academic pressures, placement pressures, jostling to find a place in the cohort and personal life and commute and sometimes people are living separately to their family and having great amounts of travel it is not unheard of that people decide to quit their doctoral psychology training and I know that if you're
团队并拥有一个有凝聚力的环境，比如当我是住院病人时，参加茶舞之类的活动，美好的回忆，但那并不是助理心理学家的角色。但是的，我们不是在谈论那个，我们谈论的是那些感觉完全没有利用你技能的事情。你努力工作才培养了这些技能。当然，正如我所说，在这个时候，人们可能第一次担任临床心理学实习生的角色。学术压力、实习压力、在群体中寻找位置、个人生活、通勤，有时人们与家人分开居住，还要长途跋涉。人们决定放弃博士心理学培训并不罕见。我知道如果你
an aspiring psychologist yourself and you haven't yet been offered doctoral training that when you hear that it feels like oh you've taken a place and then you've not completed your training this is a place I could have had this is a place someone else could have had but all of those factors sort of need to just be put to one side we can't be too worried about what other people think about us because you matter and we can't know that we're going to like doing anything if we've not done it before you know we do things with the best intentions with the best resources we've got on any given day but that might be different when we actually get there and we've got more insight into what that role is like or we thought that might be sustainable for a period of time but actually when we get there or perhaps some of the variables
自己是一名有抱负的心理学家，还没有获得博士培训机会，当你听到这个时，会觉得：“哦，你占了一个名额，然后却没有完成培训。这是我本可以拥有的名额，这是别人本可以拥有的名额。”但所有这些因素都需要被放在一边。我们不能太担心别人怎么看我们，因为你很重要。如果我们以前没做过，我们就无法知道自己是否会喜欢做某事。我们带着最好的意图、用我们当天拥有的最好资源去做事，但当我们真正到达那里，对那个角色有了更多了解时，情况可能会有所不同。或者我们认为这在一段时间内是可持续的，但当我们真正到达那里，或者也许一些变量
change and you're less resourced you know perhaps someone in your family becomes ill or your own health starts to falter and that suddenly becomes untenable for you um and so you know you might be listening to this thinking i'm not sure this old training malarkey is for me, or I'm not sure this doctoral training malarkey is for me, you know, because you might decide to defer and have a place on the same cohort next, same course next year, if that's a possibility, or you might decide this uni is not fit for you, you know, kind of locally, you know, you need something closer to where you grew up or, you know, away from where you grew up or you know away from where you grew up maybe that's part of the problem but you might decide whatever psychology or mental
发生了变化，你的资源减少了——也许你家人生病了，或者你自己的健康开始恶化，这突然变得让你无法承受。所以，你可能在听这段节目时想：“我不确定这套培训对我来说是否合适，或者我不确定这套博士培训对我来说是否合适。”因为你可能会决定推迟，如果可能的话，明年在同一批次中占有一席之地。或者你可能会决定这所大学不适合你，在当地，你需要离你成长的地方更近，或者远离你成长的地方。也许远离你成长的地方是问题的一部分。但你可能会决定，无论你从事什么心理学或心理健康角色，即使是博士项目，这只会让你如此不快乐，让你在身体上感受到那种感觉——这让你感到恶心、迟钝，感觉世界的重量压在你的肩膀上，让你觉得这消耗了你所有的思想。所以我只是想表达我的同情，如果你现在发现自己处于这种境地，并给你许可去做你需要做的事情来照顾自己。但请务必向你关心和信任的人寻求支持。如果感觉安全的话，请与你的督导交谈。如果你在接受培训，如果感觉安全的话，请与你的个人导师交谈。如果感觉不安全，
health role you're in even if it is a doctoral program that this is just making you so unhappy giving you that you know really really connect to your body where you're feeling that in your body this is just making you feel so sick and sluggish and it feels like the weight of the world is pressing on your shoulders with making it feel like this is just consuming all of your thoughts so I just wanted to extend my compassion if you are finding yourself in this position right now and to just give you permission to do what you need to do to look after yourself. But yeah, please do reach out for people's support that you care about and that you trust. You do speak to your supervisor if that feels safe to do so do speak to your um if you're on training speak to your personal tutor if that doesn't feel safe
与你的同伴交谈，如果感觉可以的话，与你的课程主任交谈。与当地的其他临床医生交谈，或者与实习单位的人交谈。你不需要有这种感觉，这不正常。通常，进行第一次对话的负担感觉是最困难的。但如果我们不寻求帮助，人们并不总是会想到提供帮助。所以，你需要做出适合你的决定。但请尽量不要孤立地做出决定。请确保你至少让你的家人和支持系统参与进来，以确保你在实际和情感上得到照顾。所以我希望你觉得这是一期有用的节目。很高兴能与你交谈。
speak to your cohort speak to your um course director if that feels okay um speak to another local clinician um you know speak to someone on placement or you know speak to, you know, speak to someone on placement or, you know, speak to someone, you know, you don't have to feel this way, this is not okay. And often the burden of having that first conversation can feel like the most difficult time. But if we don't ask for help, then people don't always think to offer it. So yeah, you need to make the decision that's right for you. But please try not to make that in isolation. Please try to make sure that you're at least including people in your family, your support systems to make sure that you're going to be looked after practically and emotionally. So I hope you found this a useful episode. It's been my pleasure to speak with you.
请一定要在社交媒体上与我联系。我在大多数地方都是Dr. Marianne Trent。加入Facebook上的免费群组“Aspiring Psychologist Community”。如果你需要更多支持，欢迎参加31日晚上7:30在我的所有社交媒体平台（除了TikTok，不在TikTok上）举行的问答活动。如果你需要更多支持，欢迎加入“Aspiring Psychologist”会员，更多详情请查看我的社交媒体或节目说明。非常感谢，请善待自己，一定要善待自己。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我很快就会在下一期节目中与你见面。
Please do come and connect with me on my socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent most places um and yeah come and join the free community uh the aspiring psychologist uh community free group on Facebook um and yeah if you would welcome more support come along to the Q&A on the 31st um across all of my socials at 7 30 p.m um apart from TikTok notok not on tiktok and um yeah if you would like even more support come and join the aspiring psychologist membership more details on my socials or in the show notes thank you so much be kind to yourself please please please be kind to yourself thank you so much for being part of my world i'll catch up with you very soon for the next episode
《Aspiring Psychologist》播客。保重。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《Aspiring Psychologist》，我是Marianne博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《Clinical Psych Collective》这本书，我发现关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有
of the aspiring psychologist podcast take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psych collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no
完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为临床心理学家的完美途径，这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。